we decided to give our AI reporter a
persona but that involves an entirely
different sort of type of AI
um these are called
um oh my gosh I've forgotten the word
generative adversarial networks I think
they're called Chris these adversarial
networks that create sort of effectively
deep fake technology yeah and that that
is another equally fast moving and
really impressive part of AI but we
pulled two bits together there to give
it that and it for that all we did is we
took somebody from The Newsroom our
producer Hannah and we trained we we got
a quick recording of her about a four
minute recording of her reading
essentially random stuff it happened to
be some old scripts from reports that
I'd written she read them out into
camera
that was enough to train the AI both on
how she looks and her mannerisms and but
also Her speech and once we got that we
could put any text we wanted into our AI
Avatar and it would read a report so we
decided to take the take the scripts
that the that Chris's AI the chat GPT
powered AI had generated and plonked
that into our AI Avatar to get a Persona
to our reporter and the Persona is
physically very convincing indeed were
there any flaws with that side of things
well it's interesting we've been playing
around with these for a bit and I it
seems to be that like like the language
AIS these are improving very quickly as
well and some of the earlier ones we
looked at were quite robotic
um there aren't particularly good facial
expressions effectively not very natural
they they sound and look a little bit
robotic
um the ones that we used hey Jen in
California
um we sent them this four minute video
and what we got back was really quite
convincing I mean a few few little
quirks sometimes and again with a lot of
these AIS you can run them once and get
one output run again you get a slightly
different version of that but it was
pretty natural and really quite
believable right I've got a clip here
that we can hopefully play
um just to give listeners an idea of how
the AI reporter sounded but as our
expert
expertise given the projected increases
in severity of these heat waves there's
an urgent call for robust policy
responses from climate change adaptation
strategies to more funds for Community
cooling centers during periods of
extreme heat
I was I found it very impressive
actually seeing how convincing
she is and she's been described in The
Newsroom by one of the management here
as someone who looks like she might have
just graduated from journalism school
which I think we all sounded a bit like
that when we graduated didn't we
um but actually you know physically it
was very convincing in terms of actually
pulling a television report like that
together using AI how did you both go
about doing that well I mean I think
Chris we recognized given the time and
the tools we had at a disposal
we couldn't get the AI to actually
complete the entire process you know
generate video and also there's a sort
of an ethical question there do you want
your AI journalist to make up the video
to go with its report if it's if it's
based on rule of Entry facts it's trying
to do a news story we decided we should
use real picture from our Archive of of
various um events and things to to
inform it but also because we weren't
able to sort of teach
um a video editing software uh using AI
tools that that's currently beyond the
scope of what we think is available out
there is that fair to say
yeah I would say so like there's a lot
of talk about what they call multimodo
that's when we kind of could get like
text video and uh let's say images I
guess we already have images all of this
into one model so what if chat GPT could
generate like videos so we haven't seen
that yet but I hear multi-modal is kind
of the next thing that could be coming
soon right
Tom were you impressed with the TV
report I was I had to say my initial
impression was how very good it was at
emulating this the style of writing you
know short Punchy sentences
with you know declarative statements and
then the the ai's ability to organize
its thoughts in a kind of logical way
and even this kind of it's a it's a bit
inside Baseball hit but this thing
called a piece to camera the bit the
reporter says to camera it's sort of got
the tone of that writing but in the
right sort of part of the report too
and I was sort of Blown Away I actually
asked Chris I was like you know how is
it so good at doing this something that
we we haven't told it how to do right
what was I mean I can't remember what
you told me Chris why it had some sense
of of how to do a TV report given we
hadn't told it what one looked like
yeah we talked about like uh I can't
explain like remember how many thousands
of I guess news scripts uh the model has
read in its training data so when you
talked about like piece to camera I
think it was yeah I have never heard of
that but you said that you did quite a
good job at actually explaining what uh
or emulating a piece to camera yeah
script yeah yeah which is absolutely
that's our that's our lingo for
essentially talking to the camera yeah
in a in a TV report so in that way it
was kind of scary oh my God it can it
can write a TV script like I do
um and it did it in 20 minutes
longer than that even on a busy news day
do you know what I mean so it was
impressive on some levels where did it
fall down I think what was clear from
the kind of Stories We got
it doesn't really understand what news
is and kind of how would it If all we're
giving it is what's already out there in
the use so it definitely had an idea of
of how new stories should look so often
it was taking two things that were being
reported in the news you know spending
pressures on the NHS plus increased
waiting times and saying uh you know
take those two things and discuss but a
lot of its ideas were quite what I would
say sort of feature article a kind of a
step back and analyze two sides of a
story it wasn't able to sort of see and
react to things in the news in the way
the news reporter does but I don't think
that is necessarily A criticism of the
Ala it's more a criticism of the fact AI
is currently generate text they generate
natural language but they don't have an
awareness of what's going on around them
if you could improve and there probably
are ways you could do that again if we
were building an AI ourselves some sort
of awareness of what's out are in the
news they could possibly do that quite a
bit better